hace 8 años rildo Angels fundó este club
de tiro en nitery cerca de Río de
Janeiro
su pasión por las pistolas y los fusiles
viene de años atrás
para este militar reservista el acceso a
un arma es un derecho inalienable de la
población que el presidente bolsonaro
intentó asegurar a golpe de decreto
sin embargo la Corte Suprema del
Congreso tumbaron todas las leyes que
amplían el porte de armas el camino
encontrado fue triplicar el arsenal de
coleccionistas y tiradores deportivos
el nivel ideal que queremos alcanzar no
se refiere a la cantidad de armas de
fuego es una cuestión de democracia si
no quieres tener armas está bien pero no
luches contra mi derecho de querer tener
una lo ideal es que toda la población se
acostumbre a este derecho que es la
libertad y luego cada uno escoja lo que
hace
rildo saluda con entusiasmo la elección
de 23 nuevos parlamentarios que
integrarán el lobby de La bala en el
congreso este militar niega que los
tiradores deportivos preparen una
insurrección Armada en caso de derrota
de bolso
está más que probado que con toda esta
Liberación entre comillas que tuvimos si
hubiésemos querido hacer algo ya lo
hubiéramos hecho desde hace mucho tiempo
nuestros derechos han sido totalmente
cercados al tumbar los decretos del
presidente y nos mantuvimos siempre en
La Paz más absoluta
Brasil tiene una gran tradición
armamentista la primera medalla olímpica
en 1920 fue en la modalidad de tiro
deportivo
algunos investigadores alertan sobre el
riesgo de que está proliferación de
armas asociada a una flexibilización de
los controles acabe beneficiando el
crimen
ya tenemos un impacto en diferentes
formas de violencia violencia contra la
mujer y fortalecimiento de la actuación
del crimen organizado es importante
también recordar que la defensa del
armamento de la población hace que se
mande un mensaje errado de que la
violencia es una forma legítima de
resolución de conflictos en una
democracia
en su opinión el avance del lobby de las
armas representa un retroceso en el
estatuto del desarme que desde 2003
intenta reducir la circulación de armas
y establece pena más duras para crímenes
como el porte ilegal o el contrabando